hello and welcome to buying and selling
in freet topl RuneScape episode three so
yeah last episode we actually made some
really good progress we're up to almost
400k uh and it looks like we should be
able to finish the series in about five
episodes maybe uh if we go at the same
Pace we're going now um yeah so we're
going to jump right into it here uh
we're going to start off by finding uh
the most expensive item we're going to
buy which is going to be the adant full
Helm I do this first just because it's
easier to buy the most of the expensive
first and then go for the cheaper items
uh so what we're going to try to do is
buy them for 20K each and hopefully sell
them for 30 you can kind of see the
graph there has kind of been going up
and down the last month so yeah we're
going to try the ad in full Helms and
addition to this we're going to put an
offer in for Pure Essence we're going to
buy about 200k worth of the pure Essence
uh so hopefully we will the pure Essence
we'll definitely get probably make 20K
off that uh hopefully these full Helms
will sell for about a 10K profit giving
us 50k on that and uh hopefully we can
sell the rest of our anma play legs from
the previous episode and just get our
money back from that so yeah I will
leave these in for an hour or two or at
least as long as it takes to buy and
sell them both and I will be right
back all right uh so we ended up
ditching the adant full Helm because it
wasn't buying we left it in for a couple
hours and replaced it with this other
item the admin PL legs te which we
bought for 500 each uh we didn't buy 60
of course but we bought about eight of
them eight for 500 each so that's we're
need a lot of money on that one uh we
did sell the pure Essence for a 20K
profit you can see right there and we
did sell the rest of our PL legs off not
for a whole lot but we got rid of them
so that's fine okay so what we're going
to start off by doing is we're going to
sell off these admin play legs T which
we got for 500 GP each we're going to
sell them for 6,000 each and yeah we
sold three of them instantly uh for I
guess 6 2 200 or something so that's
good that should sell quickly then uh
for the second item we're just going to
do another bit of pure Essence cuz they
actually have been buying and selling
fairly quickly and it again there's not
a lot of free to playay thems so it
takes me a while to even come up with
one good item to flip uh mind you three
so yeah we're going to put in pure
Essence here and then just find one more
item all right we just wasted so much
time trying to find an item here about
10 minutes ah Hadad on recording so
we're going to trim this down because it
was kind of boring what we ended up
settling on was am of magic we couldn't
really find a better item at this time
so we're just going to go with that for
now just to make sure we taking
advantage of the three offer slots we do
get so yeah we'll put an offer in for
the am of magic I think the the trimmed
piece of armor the plate legs we're
flipping right now should go very quick
and uh the P Ence should finish while
I'm asleep all right so I'll see you in
the morning
all right so we've bought and sold
pretty much everything we have uh go
away um on the Amulet of magic we
probably made only 7 or 8K but it was
pretty quick and easy we ended up buying
300K of the pure Essence sorry 30k of
the pure Essence and um you didn't see
there but I did sell off two of the
adamant plate legs t for 9,000 actually
and then the rest for
6,000 uh so we made an average Maybe
sevenk in each of those um of the
adamant plate legs t uh so seven eight
so we probably made 50k on those that's
pretty good too pretty happy with these
trimmed pieces of armor so far all right
so uh next we're going to try the am of
magic again we're just struggling to
find some good items here we really have
like 50 minutes of footage of me just
trying a bunch of different items out
losing money each one um so we're just
gonna try the am of magican why not I
mean it was easy quick and yeah we just
get the third item here now we try a
couple different ones here we try Adam
and play like T which don't really pan
out you can see here me just checking
the margin now I did this like 20 times
that you're not seeing here but uh yeah
so adamin playle G didn't work out I
think i' try like admin kite Shield
trimmed or all these wacky items that no
one ever uses I guess um but yeah the
adamant kite Shield you see coming up
here
probably yeah so that didn't work out I
just I didn't buy it at all but it just
got so expensive that I couldn't really
check the margin so what I ended up
settling on was the the adamant full
Helm
T which had a pretty good margin on it
yeah let's see here so yeah we put it in
to buy ends up buying for somewhere
around 6K I believe yeah
6,92 and we're selling it and it comes
up for 2K or something like that uh see
there's about a yeah 4K margin on that
so we're going to try that out I don't
expect to buy many of these CU I don't
know who the hell even has these but if
we each one we buy we'll make four 5K
off of so yeah we'll leave these in for
a while and check back in a
minute okay so I was away longer than I
thought and uh so it's good we sold all
the pure Ence uh 30k profit on that one
pretty consistent uh was actually amul
of magics we made almost 30k off of as
well we got like a 200 GP margin on that
uh we actually ended up buying 16 of
these full Helms so hopefully we can
sell these back because actually was a
little quicker than I expected but you
know can't hurt we only bought them for
2,000 each so we're going to put an
offer in here for close to 7,000 I think
because you see up here I go to check
the margin again just to see if it's
changed and it doesn't seem like
anyone's actually selling them so I
would be one of the only people again it
can sometimes bug when you're in
different worlds but you know we're just
going to put them in for about 7,000
each so we're just going to actually try
to buy some more of these cuz they were
buying pretty quickly and it looks like
I should definitely be able to least
double my money on these ones so we're
going to put another offer in
for another 2,000 I think yeah we're
just going to check it again yeah we'll
just do 2,000 again and we'll buy
another 20ish of these cuz I was only
gone for a couple hours and then we
managed to buy 15 20 I can't remember
exactly uh but yeah so they're pretty
quick moving surprisingly I've never
seen one of these ever so that's weird
uh and we're end up just going to do
some pure Essence here so why I'm doing
this I'm not trying to do it all the
time but it's a kind of a fallback item
and it's pretty much just an easy 40K uh
so and we want to keep the offer slots
filled because we only have three of
them all right so we have sold all the
pure Essence uh made 40K off of all
those and we also managed to sell off
all the adamant full Helm T's now
they're taking forever to sell so I
reduce the price down to 4K a piece so
we're still making 2K profit in each one
giving us about 38k on the full Helms
40K on the pure Ence and then we still
have a couple of the Helms to sell back
uh we're going to try to sell them for a
little bit more but still should get 8
10K from those two yeah so what we're
going to do is we're just going to sell
the these quickly and um then we're
going to put another offer in for the
pure Essences cuz I have a new item I
want to try out but I'm not going to buy
them in a huge amount of bulk just
because I'm not sure how well they're
going to work uh and the P Ence have
been pretty consistent money so yeah
we'll just put these in here I think I'm
going to buy 5 50,000 of the pure
Essence and then we're going to try a
team capes out now I kind of wish I
tried them earlier because they seem to
have pretty high margins they do take a
while to buy
but um they yeah I've seen you can buy
team P for like 200 and sell them for a
th000 stuff like that uh so we're going
to try out a couple the team capes here
there's so many of them so it might take
a while to find one that works um so
yeah just give me a second I'll try to
find a good one
here all right so you can kind of see my
uh purchase history here I've tried a
couple of the capes and uh the team 50
Cape seem to have the best margin on
them now I should have checked how often
they buy and sell but we'll see if this
works
out a lot of the team capes really don't
have many people buying them for
whatever reason like the team cap nine
seems to be actively traded a lot more
not sure about the team cap 50 but it
had a pretty good margin on it like four
or 500 so we'll give it a try and uh
we'll just see how many we can
buy so I left in overnight and I bought
like almost all of them I have like 400
I was trying to buy and I must have got
like 350 of them let's see 352 yeah oh
God I don't know if I can sell all these
but whatever we got 350 team Cape 50s
for about 180 each we also bought all
the pure Essence so yeah we should get
50k off the pure Essence capes I mean I
could be in there for a week I don't
know how long that's going to take who
needs that many uh but yeah teamk 50
we're going to try to sell back for 700
let's see no 550 approximately so I mean
if we do sell them all we should be
getting nearly double our money
more yeah so you see my um purchase
history here we're actually get about
130k off the team capes um so yeah I'll
make sure to make like an update video
in um November when they finally all
sell uh but yeah so we'll just buy one
more team Cape here we're going to try
team Cape nine it's much more actively
traded in this one so I'd feel a little
bit better about having a huge amount of
Team Cape nines um but yeah so we'll
just check the margin here I believe it
was about somewhere around 300 yes we're
buying them for 495 each
and um sorry they're being sold for 495
each and we're going to try to buy them
for around 100 so that's a really good
margin and yeah the team Cape NES have a
like a lot more people are buying them I
guess different ping Clans use the team
Cape 9 so whatever uh so yeah there's a
400 GP margin on the team cape 9es and
we'll try to buy about
200 all right so we actually sold all
the teamk 50s I'm happy about that we're
not stuck with those and we made like
130k off that and that I did leave leave
him in all day so I mean it wasn't super
quick but man that worked pretty well
and yeah so no complaints there we're
slowly sing off the pure Essence for
whatever reason this has taking a
while yeah I still can't believe they
sold so quick but I'm not complaining
too much yeah look right there that's
130k almost on the dot man that was easy
so yeah we're going to try to sell these
team cap 9es back so we're just going to
have to recheck the margin cuz these
things flip around quite a bit yeah so
team Cape 9 we're hoping to sell them
for was
uh yeah okay that's not happening okay
so they crashed on us so that's a little
unfortunate uh so I think we're just
going to try to dump these for what we
bought them for hopefully we can sell
them and lastly we're going to try
another offer for the team Cape 50s they
just worked so well the first time
there's no reason not to try them again
uh so what we ended up buying them for
is around 170 and we're hoping to for
around the 4 500 Mark uh yeah so I'll
check back when some stuff is
bought okay so what ended up happening
is we just dumped the team Cape NES for
about a 10K loss not really that big a
deal just bit annoying and a waste of
time and item slots uh what we ended up
buying was a couple of these team Cape
30 somethings 32 maybe I there's so many
of them uh yeah so we're going to try to
sell those didn't get a whole lot of
them as I was saying not a lot of the
team capes don't buy very much except
for these team Cape 50s for some reason
uh so yeah we're going to basically try
the margin crashed again so we were
going to try to sell them back for what
we bought them for again but then we
thought well it's flipping around so
much that we're just going to put in a
bit of a higher offer and see if we can
at least make some money off this so
we're going to put them in for
300 and uh yeah we'll leave those and if
not we'll lower the price again but
can't really hurt to try too much uh and
the team K 38 I guess is the one I
bought uh we bought them for just 100 GP
each or something so we're going to sell
them for an 800 GP profit you know what
screw it that's kind of lame we're going
to actually just switch this up a little
bit 17 times 600 it's not really too
much not really worth my time at this
point really so we're going to flip it
to another item here we're going to try
team Cape 7 which looks like it has
about 300 GP profit on it so that's not
too bad we're going to put a couple
hundred of these in our offer slots here
and I will check back when everything is
bought and
sold I think this is where we're going
to end the episode I'm just going to do
a final tally of all the money I've made
so far so just to have a look at what we
sold start with the pure Essence that's
easy we made 60k on the dot for the pure
Essences um the team Cape 7 we actually
ended up making R 66k off
and the team Cape 50s we got about 110k
we actually managed to sell all the team
Cape 50s for 300 which is great I was
not expecting that but that is awesome
so after everything said and done this
episode we made
about 500k which is pretty awesome I
mean this was recorded over the course
of about a week but I really wasn't
playing as much as I'd like I just
checked it every couple times a day and
most um so yeah I'm pretty happy with
our progress we're almost to the midd I
mean we're getting close to the halfway
mark and we're just on episode three so
I hope you guys enjoyed the episode I
had a lot of fun making it and I'm
really happy with our progress if you
enjoyed I would love if you left me a
comment uh anything instructive you're
happy don't like me whatever I would
like to read some of you guys' comments
if you guys would like to see more of
this kind of stuff I would really
appreciate if you just hit that
subscribe button and yeah that's all I
got to say I will see you guys in
episode 4
[Music]
[Applause]